this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and I
host Startalk welcome back to star talk
radio and it's fighting all these air
molecules like what's up with that we
win astrophysicist we should have had
private initiative going to space
decades ago but I'm embarrassed it's
taking this long we've been in space for
50 years why is it only just yesterday
private enterprise is taking some
initiative here and so I'm disappointed
that it's taken this long
that being said private enterprise will
not ever lead a space frontier not
because I don't want them to but my read
of history history tells me they can't
it's not possible space is dangerous
it's expensive
your unquantified risks combined all
those on one umbrella you cannot
establish a free market capitalization
of that enterprise who am i investors
I'm not going what are the risk I don't
know what it'll cost we haven't figured
it out yet we'll never know what's the
ROI there isn't one because we've never
done it before and we don't know what
what we might find those are the kinds
of frontiers that the history that
history of governments have undertaken
the first Europeans to the new world
were not the Dutch East India Trading
Company
it was government's funding government
missions Columbus drew the map
established where the trade winds were
where are the hostels where are the
friendlies is there food there can you
breathe the air they come back with this
information then you can establish a
capital market valuation because now you
know there are riches over here but not
there you can get here by this route but
not that one then you can turn it into a
profitable enterprise then you can
establish a capital market valuation
what did SpaceX do were they leading the
space Frontier know they hauling cargo
back and forth to the space station
NASA should never have been in that
business you don't need astronauts who
are highly trained professional
spacefarers
to be hauling goods back and forth to
space get SpaceX to do it the post
office they don't have their own planes
or if they do it's for trivial things if
they want to move mail across the
country they rent space in the belly of
Delta Airlines or mer whomever the
corporation will do it more efficiently
and they don't have to worry about the
business model for that let somebody
else do it but if you want to move the
frontier to a new place you need the
government especially where space is
involved and once that once the maps are
drawn and the risks are established then
you could farm that off to space it to
industry and that's what like I
said should have been happening decades
you